investigators don't know why an airline
baggage handler stole a passenger plane
from a major US airport but they say it
should never happen again Richard
Russell flew the 76 seat plane for more
than an hour above the Seattle area
Friday night he finally crashed killing
himself
Jamie yuccas is at Seattle Tacoma
International Airport Jamie good morning
good morning the FBI announced late
Sunday that it found parts of the
cockpit voice recorder as well as parts
of the flight data recorder the NTSB
will now look at both to try to
determine how a Verizon's airline
employee was able to take off from this
Airport fly that airplane before he
fatally crashed Witnesses on the ground
didn't know what to think when they saw
two f-15 fighter jets pursuing a horizon
air passenger plane Friday evening all
of a sudden the plane was gone and and
the island shook and I thought we had
been bombed investigators are now trying
to determine how and why Richard Russell
a nearly four-year employee assigned to
handle baggage and cargo managed to get
the Bombardier turboprop airborne his
conversation with air traffic control
was captured on tape the plane was
parked at a SeaTac Airport maintenance
area when investigators say Russell used
a tow tractor to turn the aircraft 180
degrees toward the runways Russell then
got behind the controls and positioned
the plane for takeoff during the roughly
75 minute flight air traffic control
tried persuading Russell to land safely
including at a nearby air force base i
think i mess something up there too i
wouldn't want to do that hopefully oh
they probably got anti-aircraft now they
don't have any of that stuff we're just
trying to find a place for you to land
safely russell conducted dangerous
maneuvers before crashing into a small
island he just needs some help
controlling his aircraft
that myself I play some video games
before the maneuvers that he managed to
do are definitely astonishing for that
type of so-called training that he had
Russell's family and friends say they
are shocked and heartbroken he was a
faithful husband a loving son and a good
friend this is a complete shock to us
Homeland Security has warned Congress
that stricter employee background checks
are needed at the airlines as well as
more surveillance in secured areas of
the airport because terrorists could try
to gain employment as an airline worker
now officials will meet with the
airlines later today to review this
incident viana Jamie thank you I know a
lot of people are just so shocked at how
someone could steal a plane so easily to
every aspect of that story is shocking
fortunately no one else was on that
flight